[Musique]
dans la mythologie romaine venus
symbolise l'amour et la beauté
mais pour les astronomes elle est plutôt
synonyme de stérilité
[Musique]
l'auto cachés sous des nuages on a
découvert que sa surface est à 500
degrés celsius et qu il y pleut de
l'acide sulfurique
l'intérêt pour venus s'est émoussée au
profit notamment du dieu de la guerre
mars où les conditions ils sont plus
clémentes à la fois pour y trouver de la
vie et pour l'explorer mais la déesse de
l'amour et peut être fertile
il pourrait y avoir de la vie en ce
moment même sur vénus des astronomes
viennent dé découvrir de la phosphine un
gaz qui sur terre
edit à la présence de vie on parle pas
ici de panda ou de crapauds mais de
microbes l'affût chine est un gaz
excrété par certaines bactéries ce qu'on
vient détecté en fait
seddiki valant d'un pet de microbes
mais comment est-ce possible avec les
conditions infernales qui règne sont
venus venus et la soeur jumelle de la
terre
dans sa jeunesse elle aussi avait des
océans
l'hypothèse c'est que la vie s'est
développée venus a aussi des volcans
beaucoup plus actif qui si ils ont
rempli l'atmosphère de gaz toxiques
l'effet de serre s'est emballé l'eau a
disparu
la vie aussi du moins à la surface
[Musique]
la vie aurait trouvé refuge dans son
atmosphère à 50 km d'altitude où les
conditions sont plus clémentes
c'est là qu'on a découvert de la
phosphine ce qui veut dire que les
bactéries et survivent depuis des
centaines de millions d'années
mais pour l'instant tout repose sur des
observations indirects
[Musique]
les astronomes ont utilisé des
télescopes radios les plus puissants de
la planète car venus émet des ondes de
différentes fréquences mais des
molécules dans son atmosphère en bloque
certaines ces trous dans signal qu'on
reçoit sont comme une empreinte digitale
ils permettent de dire quel gaz sont
présents et dans ce cas-ci caveau speed
et les quantités sont telles que la
seule explication possible pour eux
c'est une forme de vie active en ce
moment mais en sciences une affirmation
extraordinaire exige des preuves
extraordinaires et pour récolter ses
preuves il faut s'y rendre avec des
sondes
[Musique]
tu as découverte se confirme ce serait
la toute première forme de vie
extraterrestre
la question de savoir si nous sommes
seuls dans l'univers pourrait être
résolu par un modeste pet de microbes
[Musique]